Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning everyone.
My name is John, one of the pastors here.
If you are new to our church, we're
so grateful you would take a step
and uh, be here with us today.
Uh, but also if you call Henderson Hills home,
it's always great to see you as well.
We love being together like this. Okay?
So raise your hand if you want to be blessed by God.
Okay? Never hand if you didn't raise your hand.
I got some questions for you
so we can talk later about that.
But, uh, but I wonder something though, if we took
that a step further
and we ask the question, okay, yeah, you raised your hand,
but, but why do you want God's bless?
We probably get a wider variety of answers.
Somebody might say, well, it it to make me happy
or to enjoy my life more,
or to make things go well for my family.
And I, I think if, if we even took it a step further
and we injected truth serum
and we had to be really brutally honest,
what we might see is
that some would say we want God's
blessing so that we're rich.
We want God's blessing so that
we're healthy perfectly all the time,
or that we have a, a prominent job
that everybody looks up to.
The problem is that all of those reasons are inadequate
for why we should seek God's blessings.
That's the direction that Psalm 67 is
going to lead us to today.
And so if you're not there already, turn
with me to God's word.
Psalm 67, roughly in the middle, you open it up,
you'll probably hit Psalms there.
Continuing our years long journey through the Psalms,
just one by one kind of summers hit
and miss throughout the year as well.
Now this psalm we're gonna look at today is very short.
It's only seven verses long,
but it's very important the Jews would often read it at the
end of every Sabbath.
In fact, in the early 18 hundreds, the Church
of England said that this psalm should be read at
every worship gathering.
It also reflects the blessing that the priests were
to pronounce, say,
over God's people every time they gathered numbers.
Chapter six verses 24 through 26.
This is what the priests were to say,
that the Lord bless you
and keep you, the Lord make his face shine upon you
and be gracious to you.
The Lord lift up his countenance, his face upon you
and give you peace.
That's what God told the priest to say
to the people every time.
But again, though, Psalm 67 will show us why we are
to seek God's blessing,
which again may be a little different than we might have
thought originally.
So look at Psalm 67.
I'm gonna read the whole thing to begin with
to the choir master with stringed
instruments, a psalm, a song.
Remember these were, these were supposed to be read
and sung at times.
This one especially may God be gracious to us
and bless us and make his face to shine upon us.
Sounds familiar, right?
Sayah that your way may be known on earth, your saving power
among all nations.
Let the peoples praise you, oh God,
let all the peoples praise you.
Let the nations be glad and sing for joy for you.
Judge the peoples with equity
and guide the nations upon earth.
Sayah, let the peoples praise you.
Oh God, let all the peoples praise you.
The earth has yielded its increase.
God, our God shall bless us, God shall bless us.
Let all the ends of the earth fear him.
God, thank you for your word this psalm,
that's one of my favorites.
So deeply felt in my soul. Thank you God for this word.
And I pray that you would make our hearts today, every one
of us good soil that this word would plant in
that heart soil
and it would bear fruit 30 fold, 60 fold, a hundred fold.
Give us eyes to see it.
Give us ears to hear it and a willingness to receive it
and to act on it in your spirit's power.
Help us God for your glory. In Jesus' name. Amen.
So we, we can take this on its own,
but if we were to trace this psalm, the roots
of it all the way back, we would find that it's founded,
it's rooted in God's covenant promise to Father Abraham
who had many sons, many sons had.
Wait, okay, I'm not gonna keep going
because that's gonna get in your head, right?
So sorry about that already. I've had that in my all week.
So, uh, but
but seriously all the way back in Genesis chapter 12 verses
one through three, listen to what God says to Abraham.
The Lord said to Abraham, Abraham, go from your country
and your kindred
and your father's house to the land that I will show you
and I will make of you a great nation.
And I will bless you
and make your name great so that you will be a blessing.
I'll bless those who bless you, him who dishonors you.
I will curse. And in you all the families
of the earth shall be blessed.
So this sets the agenda for Abraham's life,
but it also sets the agenda for his descendants, right?
This was the Abrahamic covenant that God made
where this set the tone
because this man who at the time was not a worshiper
of Yahweh, God called him and set him apart.
This man who was at the time childless with his wife
and they were both too old to have children.
God says, I'm gonna make you a large nation by
that meaning you're gonna have a huge family.
And so that, that's our first point.
Before we get too far into this, in relation to Psalm 67,
the first point is that Abraham was blessed by God.
Like we don't just take Psalm 67 on its own.
We have to remember this was God's blessing of Abraham.
And you saw it in Genesis 12. God said, I will bless you.
Not I might, I will,
but did you notice why God was gonna bless Abraham
so that you will be a blessing?
That was Genesis 12.
I will bless you so that you will be a blessing so
that in you all the families of the earth will be blessed.
That was the end of verse three, that God blessed Abraham
to be a blessing to others.
That word for families at the end of verse three,
it means people, groups, distinct cultures.
You see it repeated throughout the Old Testament,
even in the New Testament, kinda the gentile idea of
of family groups clans
that in Abraham, through Abraham, God was going
to bless all the families.
And so that means yes, materially,
financially God was gonna bless Abraham to bless others.
But first
and foremost what we trace the lineage of the Bible,
the the scarlet thread throughout is that this blessing
of the families of the earth was gonna come
through Abraham's family lineage.
That you track it all the way through
and eventually you see the Messiah, Jesus,
a descendant of Abraham in you, all the families
of the earth would be blessed.
So again, notice God didn't give Abraham all
that he gave him materially
financially, yes, all those things.
But even a family, Isaac
and the lineage like he, God didn't give him that merely
for Abraham alone, that his blessing came on Abraham.
So that Abraham could have all the things that he wanted.
Is that why? No. He was blessed to be a blessing to others,
which is what his faith in God brought about as we track it
through the Bible.
That's what forms the backdrop for Psalm 67.
And in verse one, we've already seen the
callback to the blessing.
The priests were to give, in Psalm 67, they call back
to number six, God be gracious to us.
God shine your face upon us. God bless us.
Number six, that blessing was a reminder
of Abraham receiving that promise from God.
They were to bless the people.
Now, Psalm 67 picks it up
and says, Israel, hey Israel, you were
to seek God's blessing too.
Abraham was blessed by God.
Israel, throughout your history seek God's blessing.
You are to seek his blessing. 'cause this is a request here.
This is a prayer saying, God, we ask you to bless us God.
God shine your face upon us.
Even that little word sayah, we kind
of skate over that really fast.
It's a Hebrew where they indicated some kind of a pause,
a musical interlude maybe.
But notice where it sits here right
after verse one, it says, you need to pause and consider
and think about what just was said in verse one, just
to sit on that request for God's blessing.
Stop for a moment and consider
that you're asking the God of the universe to bless you.
Wow. But what we come
to find out throughout this short Psalm is
that their reason
to seek God's blessing was the same as Abraham's.
It's throughout the Psalm,
especially though seen in the structure.
And this is where you have to read carefully.
And this is something that I wanted just
to show you a little bit,
because remember these psalms are poetry.
Doesn't mean they follow logical flow very often.
Like you read the New Testament, Paul's writing a letter,
he's making an argument, he's tracing something.
The Psalms don't work like that.
They're poetry, which means that you can
often find patterns.
And one tool to find a pattern is called chiasm.
C-H-I-A-S-M.
Chiasm is where the, the first verses parallel the last
verses, and then the next set
of verses you come up from the bottom
and those parallel each other and then so on and so forth.
You come in both ways
and they parallel each other all leading to finally
the middle is what the author was emphasizing.
And you wouldn't pick that up normally,
but you have to read it carefully and look at it.
And so I was trying to think of a way to illustrate this.
Well, think of like the beak of a puffin.
So when you look at that, by the
way, those are not penguins.
I, I thought that my whole life, like those are part
penguin, but they're not, they're birds.
So, uh, but but you see the, the beak, right?
The top and bottom, it looks like a almost a greater than
sign where it comes down and in to the point.
So the directions of both are heading towards the
middle to the point.
That's what's happening here in Psalm 67.
So the rest of your life, when you see a puffin, you think
of Psalm 67, okay?
But it has a really clear castic structure.
And so I'm gonna show you on the screen here that
that verses one and two are parallel to verses six
and seven, the end
because it's opening with a prayer for God to bless them.
And what does it end with? It ends
with probably a future prophetic fulfillment of
that same blessing.
Those go together.
But then you see, notice, this is where it's really clear.
Verse three and verse five, you come up
and to the right a little bit
because those are identical verses, right?
Verse three and verse five are exactly the same
where they're saying, God,
we want all peoples to praise you.
What'd that leave us with? Verse four, right?
It's pointing to the the point verse four
where it says this middle of the sandwich,
you might say the hinge, the point of the whole thing.
What does it say? It's a prayer for the gladness
of the nations in God as they submit
to his righteous rule, his sovereign guidance.
That's what the author wanted to emphasize.
Now we'll get to the nations in a moment,
but if that was to be true of all the nations,
Then it certainly was to be true of Israel as well, right?
Like if it's God, we, we want let all the nations be glad.
We should be glad in you as well.
And so just taking it first at surface level here,
Israel was to seek God's blessing for their own gladness.
First, like to seek the blessing of God
for their own gladness.
Verse one, they were to ask God to bless them,
to be gracious to them, to make his face shine upon them.
Which is just a symbolic way of saying that God was smiling
over them, that God's favor
was resting on them.
God, we want you to smile when you look at us, want you
to look with pleasure.
And so what we see is at least
and the very least, those blessings of God were to
increase Israel's enjoyment of God.
That they were glad in him as their king,
that they were overjoyed,
that this God would look at them with favor.
God had set Israel apart to be his,
to be his cherished possession, to be his very own people
out of all the nations.
Not because they deserved it
or because they were the biggest.
He just chose to take them as his
That should fill them.
And they should sing with this joy.
That's what Psalm 67 is saying to them First,
you should be glad in him.
But what we again see here is
that God was blessing them so
that they would be a blessing to the nations.
So that the nations would be glad as well.
Israel seek God's blessing so that you are glad in God.
And so that the nations are glad in God.
Again, that that's verse four, right?
The meat of the sandwich. Remember the the
very middle point of it.
Let the nations be glad
that was the first line of verse four.
Let the nations be glad.
In other words, God was blessing Israel so
that he would be known among the nations.
They were to publicly live out a response to his
guidance, to his salvation, to his good way
that he told them how to live to his saving power,
to his judgment that saved them all of that they were
to live out such a way
and be so compelled by their own gladness in him
that they wanted all peoples to be glad in him as well.
Like so transformed by this grace of God
To say we want all the nations to know him.
That was what we saw for Abraham.
Remember back in Genesis 12,
and it was the theme that Isaiah picked up
Isaiah 49 verse six.
God says, it's too light a thing
that you should be my servant to raise up merely the tribes
of Jacob and to bring back the preserved of Israel.
I will make you a light to the nations
that my salvation may reach to the end of the earth.
So what this means is
that God would give Israel the most joy
and he would shine the brightest like that through them
as they kept a global perspective on his blessings to them
as they saw it from God's perspective, as they expanded
this joy that they'd been given to others.
You can probably see where this is setting, can't you
as God's people today,
These Truths are still the same.
We are to seek God's blessing too.
Abraham was blessed by God.
Israel was to seek God's blessing.
We are to seek God's blessing also.
But again, not for selfish reasons.
'cause listen to how James four three says it very clearly.
You ask and do not receive
because you ask wrongly to spend it on your passions.
He's saying God's not blessing you
because you're just merely asking.
So you can spend it on yourself.
So you can use it for yourself.
God's not gonna give you anything for that.
He knows that's harmful for you.
And so he is not gonna give it but it.
But there's a difference what we're asking for here.
We're not merely to ask for God's blessings,
for our own comforts, to make our lives easier,
to one up the next guy because look how much we have.
And you don't. That's not it.
The reasons are still the same today as they were back then.
Just like for Israel, they were to seek God's blessings
to increase their gladness in God first
and then the gladness of the nations through them.
It's the same. We are to seek God's blessings first so
that we can love him more deeply.
God, we want you to bless us so we can love you more deeply.
Like he's a good father.
And so we should long for him verse one, to smile on us,
to be gracious to us, to bless us so
that we can know him more so that we can love him more and
and the more we love him, then the more abundant praise
that we saw in Psalm 67, the more
that abundant praise just pours out of our lives, out
of our mouths, the more we love him.
I mean, just think about it. We talk about
what we love, right?
Like, like when you have grandkids, you're more than happy
to post pictures on Facebook about him,
to show anybody who asks.
Like you're at some random restaurant meeting a stranger
and you're like, Hey, you wanna see my grandkids?
Like that's how you do it, right? Because you love 'em.
It's not just that though, right?
The newest gadget you purchased, you got the new iPhone,
you got the new gadget at the house,
the new system, whatever it is.
Like you, you love talking about that.
You love talking about your favorite team and how well
or how poorly they're doing.
And you can see how that just comes out of you naturally.
Or you're at the Grand Canyon, you see that sunset
and you wanna take 5,000 pictures of it
because you want everybody to know how great it was.
So I'm afraid that, I'm afraid we don't praise
God like that.
Partly because we don't love him that much.
We're not glad. We're not thrilled.
And so we sit stone faced when the gospel is proclaimed.
We, we sit there with our hands in our pockets
and don't sing at all because we just don't care that much.
And I'm not saying that to you.
I'm saying that to myself even this week.
I mean, I, I had to ask the question,
am I really that glad in God?
Like is, is it is just something that it's like,
is my gladness in him really increasing
or am I more glad in all kinds of other things instead
of him than I get to read my Bible for five minutes,
but then I get to go watch that show?
Like
am I allowing my heart to be stolen away to lesser gods
that his word even says will never satisfy?
Like how can you and I say to the nations, be glad in God
if we're not even that glad in God, If he doesn't
excite, awaken, move us.
Okay? So how do we grow in this?
Like I, we're all sitting here kind of pressed down
by God's word here, okay?
So how do we grow in this area?
Well, we look to God's word here in Psalm 67
and we begin to recall who God is, what God has done.
And we think first as this says,
we think first about his sovereign guidance in our lives,
his good way that he has worked in us and how he's led us.
And I know we might not always understand
what he's doing in the moment, but we can't help
but praise when we see the resulting
blessings of what he's done.
I mean, just think of Abraham. God said to him,
leave your house, your family, your land.
Go. He's like, okay, where am I going? I'll show you.
Like, do I need to go east or what?
I'll show you when you get there, I'll show you.
And when Abraham did
what he was called to do, what happened? God blessed
Him.
He didn't understand. He was confused.
And I look around this room
and I know so many stories
where you've suffered loss, you've had an illness,
you've had financial struggles here and there.
And yet I watch and hear me.
I'm so built up in my faith watching
people walk through story after story after story
and look back and see what God has done
and declare what God has done,
bless them in it and through it.
And so we can look at God's way, his guidance,
and we can see his blessings and we can identify
and we can celebrate.
And that is one way
to grow in our gladness in
God.
But we can also look back at his righteous judgment
as Psalm 67 says.
And we can know that that's a good thing.
Yet how do we look at judgment as a good thing?
Because the reality is that we all stand guilty
according to his standard.
If he is the judge, we're guilty for him.
So how does that spark praise?
How does that spark gladness in God
by looking at his judgment?
Because verse two also included, remember his saving power.
So he's the judge and he has saving power.
'cause just think about this, right? Our good father
has blessed us by sending his only begotten son
to be in our place for
Us To, to take
through his life, death
and resurrection on that cross in his grave coming out
of it, all of that, that that counts for us.
That that covers our whole sin, that that takes
that judgment away from us.
And that he defeats sin and death on our behalf.
And so the judgment is actually a blessing when we look
at it from that perspective.
Yes. And so that
as a believer, that is how we can know
God's blessings, right?
We can be reminded, we can grow in gladness.
That's why we preach the gospel. That's why we sing the
gospel to just increase our gladness
in God for what he's done.
We've received material blessings.
None of us in this room richer than 99% of the world
around us.
Like we've received material blessing.
We can be grateful for that.
But even more importantly,
we've received spiritual blessings
and increases our love for him when we think and reflect
and rejoice, even just
look at the second line of verse six, look at,
look at verse six here.
The earth has yielded its increase.
God, our God shall bless us,
might just skim over that really fast.
But, but this is, this is talking about not just some God
who's abstract out there.
We don't know who he is. No, this is a personal God.
This is our God. It says
'cause That's what he's wanting us to seek.
He's wanting us to seek the treasure of an intimate,
close knit relationship with God through Jesus Christ.
Not just a religious action, not just a set of morals
that I lived better than I used to.
Like an intimate relationship with the God of the universe
through Jesus Christ.
Where like Ephesians three says, we can know the love
of Christ that surpasses knowledge.
Like how do you know something that surpasses knowledge?
It's because it's in here that you may be
filled with all the fullness of God.
What a blessing. When you answered
that question at the beginning, I
wanna be blessed by God, right?
Filled with all the fullness of God. What a blessing.
Stunning. So seek it. Yes, seek it.
You may love him more.
Yet again, like for Abraham, like
for Israel, he has not given us those blessings
just for ourselves.
We are also to seek God's blessings so
that we can live sin more widely.
To love him more deeply. Yes.
And to live sin more widely.
Remember verse one, may God be gracious to us, bless us,
make his face shine upon us.
Great prayer. Keep praying that.
But verse two starts with right that
John Piper says, that's the key word of the whole verse that
bless us, God bless us God,
that your way may be known on earth.
You are saving power among all nations.
That's the reason God has blessed us.
'cause remember the core of the Psalm,
like remember the point of the puffins beak, right?
Like when you see that picture
and you see a puff, you think of this right here.
Let the nations be glad and sing for joy.
Amen. The whole thing is blessing us.
He's pointing us to let the nations be glad
that God blessing his people with guidance
and salvation would lead, like Revelation said,
re lead all people groups
to be represented around the throne of God.
Like that was God's heart from the beginning.
He's not second plan B.
Like, this is how we're gonna work this.
Oh, I guess I gotta call. No, all the people
from Genesis 12, all the families,
all the nations, Jesus, Matthew 28,
go into all nations and make disciples, right?
This is a theme. So when you tie this together,
it seems here that if we want
to increase our gladness in God,
then our hearts must be globally focused.
Like God says, if we want
to increase our own gladness in God,
which is a right desire,
our hearts should be globally focused like God says.
Because God promises to bless his people
to be a blessing to the nations.
Now, you might think I, I had to wrestle with this like,
is God just using us then We're just tools vessels, is
that, is that all we are?
No, he does it this way
because he loves the nations,
But also because he knows that our joy in all that God is
for us, it increases
as it expands into the lives of others.
Like when you can take that joy God's given you
and you can expand it into the lives of others like it,
it's doubling, tripling in your own heart
as you serve, as you give, as you.
It's so joy filling.
It's better to give than receive, right?
But I love how John Piper said it in his famous book,
let the Nations Be Glad He said, if God blesses his people
for the sake of the nations, then God is most likely
to bless us when we are planning and longing
and praying to bless the nations.
If God wants his goods to get to the nations,
he will fill the truck that's driving toward the nations.
He will bless the church that's pur pouring itself out
for the unreached peoples of the world.
And this blessing is not payment for a service rendered
its power and joy for a mission to accomplish.
When we move toward the unreached peoples,
we are not earning God's blessings.
We're leaping into the river of blessings
that is already flowing to the nations.
In other words, we're just joining God in
what he's already doing and he's gonna bless that, right?
This is why we're planning on hiring our first church
planning resident this summer.
This is why we're expanding global mission trip
opportunities left and right.
This is why we host evangelism trainings
and encouraging block parties at Christmas and July 4th
and mission outreach for VBS to your neighborhoods.
This is why we long for every single person in our church
to be involved in going, sending, praying, giving,
supporting what God is doing here in his mission work.
I read this quote. It's been said that every lamp
that is lighted is lighted to shine,
not to put under that bushel, hide.
It's to shine So that they may see your good works
and glorify your father who is in heaven.
But every lamp, every light of the world, now that you
and I are, is lighted to shine.
Which is why every worship gathering, what do we end with?
We are sent, I've changed that a little bit by the way
you say you are sent, but I'm included in that too.
We are sent.
Are sent 'cause.
'cause just like God, the Son was sent by God the Father,
and then God the Son turned to his disciples
and by extension us sent us to the nations.
Romans 10 says this, everyone who calls on the name
of the Lord will be saved.
How then will they call on him
and whom they've not believed?
How are they to believe in him of whom they've never heard?
And how are they to hear without someone preaching?
And how are they to preach
unless they are sent as it is written?
How beautiful are the feet of those who preach the good
News?
That's for each one of us, not just for the missionaries
or the pastors, every single one of us.
Some of us are called to move to other nations. Yes.
And that might be what God is calling some of you right now
to do, is to go to the nations for his glory,
for your own joy in some way, but for His glory.
Some of us are called,
but all of us are called to move toward our neighborhoods
and the nations that have moved here.
All of us, because Romans 10 leads us
to believe people can't be glad in God
if they don't know him.
And so we send, and our joy is more
full when we respond to God's blessings in these ways.
A few years ago we, we studied through the book of Judges
during our worship gatherings.
Some of you might remember that we entitled
that series identity crisis.
'cause judges is filled with God's people forgetting
who they were in relation to who God is turning away
to idol after idol.
And one of the challenges that we gave at that time was
to memorize one Peter two, nine and 10
because it reminds us of our identity in Christ
to keep us from slipping into
forgetfulness as well.
Listen to what it says.
But you talking to believers, right?
You are a chosen race, a royal priesthood,
a holy nation, a people for his own possession
that you may proclaim the excellencies of him
who called you out of darkness into his marvelous light
once you were not a people, but now you are God's people.
Once you had not received mercy, but now you have received
Mercy Like you see how beautiful that is,
how that reminds us.
But, but think about how it relates to Psalm 67,
that if you are in Abraham by faith in Christ,
if you're a part of Genesis twelve's, blessing
of all the families, that's what Galatians three says.
If you are in Christ, you are God's special,
very own cherished possession.
Like in my sin, I was far from God,
but now in Christ, I've been brought near.
I've received mercy.
I'm a part of God's people where I wasn't part of before.
Yet again, did you see why? Why did God do that?
Why did God bless that you may proclaim the excellencies
of him who called you into his marvelous light?
Do you see the gladness there?
Marvelous light, not just any light, marvelous light,
the excellencies, the the honor of who he is.
That's what we get to proclaim.
We have joyful access to him as his children,
as a part of his family.
And so, like Westminster said a long time ago, the purpose
of our lives is to glorify God
and to enjoy him forever, to receive his blessings,
to enjoy those things absolutely grow ever deeper in
our love for him.
But all of it is also so that we may use it
for his glory among the nations.
It's not just for us. It's for His glory.
And so let's seek him.
Church, let's love him
because he's made us glad
and let's live for him because he's made us glad.